oops we got some stuff to do today uh
first of
all I realized like the Mev just hasn't
been going fast enough I really needed
to be doing more on the promo side to
get more people interested in
contributing because they're just simply
too many environments and that went very
very well this morning we got a whole
bunch of DMS from new people who are
looking to contribute to stuff which is
awesome um so if you're one of those and
watching this then I'm happy to get you
set up right
now uh in the meantime though I'm going
to start going over PRS and such
from contributors I think we have one
I'm going to have to merge uh the
breakout fixes I think um let me
see obvious standouts at the moment
let me see what else what else can I get
people to do
okay so that's some good stuff to start
with
there
um that's some good stuff to start with
very
good let's get the uh this PR
here
so large refactor
to
[Music]
use
bitboard 49
bits okay that's
interesting this is
clever yeah this is clever this is more
than I would expect from a lot of new
contributors actually this is good good
work if he actually did
this this is nice Oh Hey
Jake if you actually implemented this
type of stuff well done this is more
than I expect from uh a lot of
contributors that's
uh this is cool actually doing some mask
stuff what did this guy do this guy did
it in
uh
solver this SM C++
Shenanigans yeah so I'm assuming that
your implementation will actually be a
lot simpler than this stuff here
Tech debt to some
degree I think it's technical debt to
some degree not sure the tradeoff is
good enough um well it depends on let's
let's look at the code here
here I mean I don't mind lowlevel stuff
like this it's actually fine what I mind
is generally abstraction and structure
sure
um having like a file that's 350 lines
for Connect 4 is good like what I mind
is when you get just like tons of layers
of [ __ ] that like you can't just
read the code top to
bottom I still don't know what I want to
do with these log buffers cuz
like I kind of like that it's just
separate per file like this um but it
does mean you have to paste in 50 lines
at the
top the way I just ified this in my head
was like so there is an include of
puffer net. but that include is only for
uh the compiled demo right so when you
come when you use the scon code uh it's
just binding theh so it has no
dependencies that's how I Justified this
layout in my
head okay we got connect
for
position mask
okay uh you don't need to make um you
don't need to make methods like this uh
if they're going to be empty there
there's not like an actual API it's the
way to think about this is It's a
convention not a not an API right so
what I do is I make an init method that
gets called um from like the C file if
needed right in order to do any setup or
no other way around it's called from
scyon to do any setup if needed and then
the allocate method it's because you
need these extra buffers if you're going
to use it from purec so I just use a
knit and allocate as conventions and I
also I'll use like make if it returns an
object
but it's just it's a convention it's not
an API so you don't ever need to feel
obligated to put like empty methods for
stuff from syon as well yeah well I I
mean you can if you want if you're able
to do that right now and just update it
then you can do that otherwise I'll just
do it when I pull it in right I mean I'm
not just a merge button I'm able to edit
code myself too
good top
mask bottom
top check if the last cell is
free okay so this is the top mask
and then the bottom
mask I don't know what you use this for
but
sure and then
bottom I actually don't understand what
these masks are for uh we'll see so
valid
move you can probably actually inline
some of these as well I don't know if
that'll matter valid
move mask and top mask equals
zero I don't know what this mask
is
play or equals
mask
redundant mask
plus I think this bit is redundant I
can't
tell
U I think you can just return mask or
bottom mask of
column
draw
holy
what oh I get it it's this is that the
board is full right yeah yeah this is
the board is full so I don't like to
comment stuff very often like I'm pretty
sparse on comments usually but stuff
like this where it's like bit
logic um this could definitely use a
couple like I get what the top mask is
for I don't necessarily get why there's
a bottom mask and stuff I get I can
figure out that this is this is the full
board
state but yeah either comments are more
judicious naming when you have lowl
stuff like this would be nice this is
overall though this is very nice and
readable like this is so far I'm fine
with
if okay I see that this is these are
checks I have no idea how these work but
uh yeah this is going to be I imagine
that this is a clever bit of stuff
designed in this post with bit masking
cool reviewing it cringing no you're
actually this code is pretty darn good
honestly um like stuff like this like if
you want to you could just name this
like board full or something and it
wouldn't even need a comment right
um but yeah I don't I don't actually
like code that's like super heavily
commented stuff should usually be self
explanatory it's basically only when you
have stuff that's like clever bit math
or something like this where you should
need like a couple very short things
like I just don't understand for
instance like okay I can figure out this
top mask this is like this is like a
floating mask at the top
of I think that this is a floating mask
for like where you've played the top
cell I think or no wait it's just the
top the top row
yeah so there's some details where it's
like it's hard to just read from the bit
math cuz this is like clever stuff that
you have to kind of unpack right this
isn't like normal
code minmax is
fine yeah yeah everybody should know
what Mini Max is you don't have to go
crazy
here if maximizing player win plus whenn
minus discount discount short
games interesting
see this type of thing is fine I'd
probably use a Turner for stuff like
this but that's a total nitpick has
onboarding finished nope I'm uh I am
here all day to onboard people and to
answer questions and stuff I'm currently
taking a let me like finish reviewing
this code bit but if you want uh if you
want some input on how to get started
and what might be a good spot that's
what I'm here for the goal for today is
to like merge some code get some people
up to speed and work on a couple M
things
myself without the disc count it stops
trying
early uh
interesting
so it has been seven or eight years
since I've seen min max explicitly done
let me see
one yeah I have some very minor
alterations to some code I don't know uh
I don't know Jake if it would be helpful
for once you submit that if it would be
helpful for you to watch me refactor a
couple small things live um I think
generally your code is very good here I
have like a couple small nitpicks with
things but this is is overall this is
well above the bar for puffer this is
well above the bar there are a few
things that can be improved just a
little bit um but I'm very much
nitpicking also I'm realizing that we're
probably going to horrify some people
watching this you do not have to know
how to do a bunch of bit math and Logic
for most of the environments this is a
special case most of the things will not
be like
this if it's going to lose in three
steps it treats the first and second
step as lost I'll put some changes and
then you can go wild yeah perfect okay
that's interesting I'd have to look at
the algorithm for that so it's not valid
move continue yep
perfect uh this is and position and mask
play God I'm going to actually I have to
look at this let me see how do this mmax
work
so I assume that you start at a positive
depth and then if it's zero or You've
Won or you've
draw you turn
okay yeah there's some stuff I can fix
here but then you would
return a value on the mid Max
okay
and value of
max if it's not a valid
move
okay and then what do we
do child
position child mask play
oh that's funny because the whole board
state is just a a 64
okay well we're not going to be able to
easily turn this game into like connect
end because of this but that's kind of
fine we don't really need every
environment to be super configurable and
I think I would rather just have uh
Connect 4 B just Connect 4 and be fast
so I'm happy with this this is fine um
uh child
value min
max this is good position and mask swaps
the
player that wait no that's not and
that's uh is that
exor I forget I think that's exor right
yeah okay it's been a long time since
I've done bit level
stuff maximizing player and child
value values child value
okay
wait how's this
work if not maximizing
player oh okay I see I see what this
is yeah so you have to
basically see if
like yeah because the score gets flipped
okay I
see compute and
move hardcoded opening book really
funky I couldn't find Min and Max and
C uh it's F it's F Max F or like it's
type dependent so there's a different
signature depending on the type
I think it's it's either I forget if
it's output type Max input type or input
Max output type but like you have like f
Max F and like IMAX I and stuff like
that I
think single move to opening book okay
that's fine we'll see how we train
against it right if we demolish this
thing then we'll try to make it harder
I know that I did it uh a couple times
in the Moa it was a
mistake child
position child
states without it you got some
exploitable
openings there might be something with
seeding Jake um I noticed I think it was
always doing the same
move I think that there probably needs
to be either like a symmetry break or a
seaing or something cuz I think right
now it'll just it'll take the first move
or whatever that is a specific value
probably there should be like if the
values are equal right of multiple moves
it should like have a chance to switch
to the new one or something maybe
symmetry breaking is kind of important
cuz otherwise yeah you'll learn like
deterministic policies that just wreck
it I'm not going to say that I fully
understand everything here because
obviously there's some lowlevel logic
and there's like some
stuff going on but I will say that the
code looks mostly quite clean with a
couple very small nitpicks um we will
we'll get this set up I
and single hardcoded seems enough
okay input player
action I assume there was something that
used to be here
move I'm not going to blame you for
stuff like this I do this all the time
right it's like you spend long enough on
something um and then you kind of just
stop seeing stuff until you go look at
it again
fresh I ship a bunch of dumb stuff all
the
time I'm not going to I'm not going to
nitpick you on stuff like this cuz like
I know that you know that this is silly
right the only things I'm going to
nitpick are things where it's like H you
might not know that this is
silly I was looking at whether I don't I
like this nesting pattern uh I think
that this is probably fine the way that
this is nested you could restructure it
but I think I don't really think that
you need to
okay this is a little bit
silly uh
actually wait
if uh actually this is kind of
okay cuz there's this else that's I
would have like rever like flipped this
if not valid move or whatever but yeah I
think this is fine I might I might tweak
a couple small
things and then rendering is about the
same rendering is about the
same 400 not bad at
all I think uh we clean this up we'll
get it to be probably under 400
total with a little bit of cleanup
including logging and everything and
this is a very nice Standalone
environment and we'll have a board game
for Connect
4 what do you
think of storage
huh I'm not sure of uh I'm not sure of
the question
here is this somebody telling me that I
messed up and that my [ __ ] is easy to
C no you're good I thought that I
thought you were somebody I thought you
were telling me like hey your website's
garbage and I can hack it or something
like hey you're storing your access
token stupid no so this is um these are
environments that we have here these are
all written in pure C and then they're
compiled uh to web assembly with M
script in so they're super super fast
and then the graphics for them are in
rib rib is also in C so it builds to web
assembly um so yeah like the actual
front end for this is just like
index.html all this stuff is
C and ironically I actually think that
that is easier than writing
JavaScript has the benefit of being very
fast as
well yeah the only reason this is at all
complicated is because of all this fancy
bit logic to go fast but this is good I
aspire to be this level of good okay
what if I told you that I hadn't written
C in 10 years until 3 months
ago and then directly following that I
wrote this in like I don't know a few
weeks you can kind of just learn
stuff you just got to do
it hey this is an open source project
all the stuff we're doing here is open
source we're onboarding tons of new
contributors
today welcome back awesome hey naan
Ethan where's the guy that was asking
about onboarding
um there was a guy on Twitch that was
asking about onboarding if you're still
here and have questions or stuff to get
on to I'd be happy to answer stuff while
Jake is uh fixing up this PR but yeah
basically I posted a ton of stuff on uh
on X today like hey we need more
contributors cuz these M's aren't going
fast enough and we really like I can
only write so much code myself um so
really the goal for the next release of
Li is we want to have at least 10 high
quality game environments or other types
of environments varying complexity
varying type and so on and really it's
not any harder than just writing the
games as you would normally you don't
really need to know the RL side very
well at all in order to be productive
here and I can help in those areas so
this is just a really great area where
if you know how to write decent code you
can help completely transform a branch
of science
um that is the goal for
puffer hey Joseph new to puffer going to
be digging into it a lot for production
stuff not just games yeah and this is
not just for games either like we use
games because they're really good test
cases for reinforcement learning and
they cover a lot of ground they're
relatively easy to implement uh they're
very easy to understand which is key and
they're very good for testing out
algorithms quickly uh we are going to
use this for lots of different areas and
in fact puffer does have a like there is
a a company behind puffer all the stuff
is free and open source uh but
technically you can pay for like
extended support and stuff like that and
that doesn't just apply to
games but for the most part the goal is
open source science and research first
and
foremost you got any funding for puffer
throw up some bounties and I'm happy to
swap over got a crank out to make rent
trying to write Russ and no rust yeah so
uh I will I've been very public about
this there will be bounties as soon as
puffer has Revenue I just opened up
puffer to potential business like a
month ago and the business model for
puffer is literally just you can pay for
priority features let's say that you're
working on something in industry and you
need puffer to be able to support
something in order for you to be able to
do that well or you need some eyes some
experienced R Allis on your problem
directly
or you need just like extended support
that is what puffer sells uh so as soon
as I start actually doing that business
side of work and getting a couple of
clients I will put the revenue from that
all directly back into feature bounties
and hardware and stuff until then what I
can provide is I can provide mentorship
and I can provide compute resources for
running these experiments that is what I
can provide um I'm pretty happy with
that overall it's people will start
making money as soon as I start making
money on this but for the short term my
goal is to just accelerate this as an
open source project first and
foremost I got a game can I share here
sure what's the plan for open-ended
Ms uh really the only thing that you
need for an open-ended M if you think
about it is a sufficiently complex game
where you can do lots of different stuff
within it I did a fair bit of work on
this with neural MMO and there is some
followup that is going to be coming out
to that soon there's uh some secret
environment side work but this was my
main project throughout my
PhD and
generally the only barrier to
open-endedness
whatsoever is having fast simpl to use
simulated environments that support that
type of stuff there really aren't very
many of them at the moment so if you
have a specific environment in mind that
you're like okay this would be a really
good thing to have
we'd be happy to support that type of
work as
well oh yeah I forgot to mention uh to
yikes um the choice to not uh to not
fund raise was very intentional I don't
want to be spending a lot of my time
fundraising and dealing with BCS and
worrying about like dilution and
worrying about like you know uh investor
obligations I really want to be able to
treat this as a scientific Endeavor
first and foremost
and then come up with ways to make it
profitable along the way I don't want to
have any obligation to scale this thing
into like a hugely profitable business
fast like my goals for this are more
like a profitable industry research lab
that can continue doing cool stuff that
pushes science and research
forward any environment that llms can
operate
I don't know yikes like one of
the one of the really cool things with
reinforcement learning is that you have
unlimited data um and as soon as you put
an R uh an llm in the loop like the llm
is so slow that you can't take advantage
of that unlimited data so I think that
llms are going to have a huge role to
play but I think it's going to be more
like you call an llm very infrequently
to make high level decisions and do you
run a much smaller like control model
learned control model reinforcement
learned control model in an in Loop
something like that is more likely Linux
Foundation Mozilla okay so I have enough
money to fund compute to be able to you
know keep myself in good situation and
all that I don't have enough money to
start like hiring people that's the key
thing right so I'm not doing like paid
internships um and basically as soon as
there's revenue of any sort I'll be able
to put more of it into additional
compute I want to build out a bigger
cluster that's one of the early goals
for puffer is to build a bigger cluster
out so we can support more contributors
and more projects around it as well as
some feature
bounties is there something that can be
done in RL research EG Master thesis
absolutely if you if you have experience
on that side and you would like to help
us on the benchmarking side like we
would like to ship good trained models
on all of these different environments
and um I mean there's a lot of good
analysis that can be done with that
right we've got some cool we've got some
cool setups for automated hyperparameter
tuning with carbs uh there's work to be
done on comparing hyperparameter tuning
methods and efficiency there there's
work to be done on like sensitivity
analysis of these environments under
various configurations uh there's lots
of science side work I didn't advertise
that as much on Twitter because most of
the people that are going to be coming
into this are going to be coming in from
like a I know how to code I don't have
the RL background I want to learn some
AI stuff but if you have more of that
side coming in then
absolutely I think you're right in terms
of validation inference would be a
pretty big bottleneck yeah so the main
thing there is uh you don't want to run
the llm every time step right like you
want to run the llm once every 10,000
time steps or less in order order to
make big crucial decisions a good
example of this would be like net
hack okay so like most of the time you
kind of just want to be having a little
model run around explore the dungeons
right but then every so often it's going
to be like you know you acquire such and
such item and then it's going to be like
oh okay when you acquire this item the
reinforcement learning model should
behave in such and such a way figuring
out how to wire up the high level and
the low level is going to be very
important in the future my assumption is
that there are enough people working on
language models that that problem is
going to be solved for me eventually um
what's not going to be solved if I don't
do it is getting RL to be in a fast and
usable state so that's what I'm focused
on with puffer at the
moment welcome everyone on
YouTube great time for me to mention one
of the absolute easiest ways to support
this project right now now for free is
to St the repo obviously we would love
to have more people contributing but if
you don't have the time to do that just
yet at Le start the repo it really helps
us out I also post all this stuff on X
so like all the news on this is on uh
jar is
5341 enough talking more
code let's see if we have an updated PR
from Jake
yet and uh it's likely that we're going
to have a bunch of new people wanting to
jump aboard uh today so I will do stuff
on stream and I will also jump in
Discord voice later tonight to help
people out and introduce myself to
people get to know everyone
tell uh looks like not yet okay so we'll
give him a few minutes uh anything on
the
Discord I do have some M's to look at
today as
okay some of our boxes aren't doing too
well I'm going to be back there at the
end of the month though to do some
maintenance I guess in the meantime I
can start on this other project um
shell for new contributors we have a uh
a very nice just pre-built container
that has puffer and everything set up in
it you don't have to use it but it's
I will then I'm just going to merge your
thing and then we'll make edits locally
if that sounds
okay
so going to go back to
this oh actually there's another thing
since we have a bunch of people watching
that I haven't had the time to figure
out yet I don't know if anybody has webd
experience with this um but right now we
build all of these environments with M
scripton individually and then we like
link them onto uh the main page I would
like to have it so that we can just have
one m script and build for everything
and we can put all the environments on
the main page in like a two column
format so you have like environment on
one side and then information about the
environment on the right side and have
like you know who made the environment
how to control the environment stuff
about the environment and like
that curious why the ocean hold on hold
on
Tim let me grab this and at least pull
this curious why ocean M header files
have so much implementation versus
putting that in the C file so theh files
get included from python we just include
theh as a standalone and then the C file
is for uh just the pure C demo that
doesn't run through python so if you can
build these environments just in C and
run them in C and build them for web and
put that on the web that's what the
little C file is the whole environment
logic is just in that. h and that gets
included very easily from
scon it's like a header only setup kind
of
[Music]
um yeah so I've tried to make it very
easy
um try to make it very easy for people
just like the single file format per N I
got rid of a lot of the old build script
stuff that was a pain I replaced it with
something
4 this is by Spencer and then refactored
and rebuilt uh re architected I should
say by Jake
here does this have the perf test in it
no it
doesn't hold on let me go grab the perf
test code that I just
deleted with this merge
for
how I just TP to
that
are you on the right stream are you uh
are you typing in the right chat
on H whatever I'll just redo the perf
test code real quick this is simple
that's a new uh that's a new Max total
on um the stream that's 20 viewers
welcome
everyone sent game on X not sure if it
fits the model interested in helping
where I can want to learn no limited
about RL that's totally fine honestly
the hard part is getting all the M's
built correctly and built fast if
I oh lots of
people whoa this is cool
is this in
in got three the other
day what is this written
oh I think it's j yeah it's well is the
logic in JavaScript or is it just the
front
end uh so one of the tricky things with
uh RL is you need the state logic to be
separate from the rendering and the
state logic has to be fast so 3D stuff
is good we actually we want more 3D
stuff but um we need the logic to be f F
that doesn't mean it has to be in C but
it does have to be in like something low
level just answer some stuff here
people it's pretty awesome to see the
number of people interested in this
do you have a link to reading on the
state portion might be able to structure
the code still learn uh still learning
send reading uh honestly the easiest
thing for you is going to be to look at
some of our existing environment code
like they're pretty self-contained as
tests and uh they're pretty short as
well
where's
ocean so right here in Ocean in
Dev like let's see which is one of these
that's pretty stable Hong is pretty
stable so if you just look at this link
here like the whole Logic for this thing
is like 300 lines of c um it doesn't
have to be see like I said but it's just
a very simple procedural game where all
the logic this is all the state for pong
and then at the bottom here you see that
the client is separate so you make the
client completely separately from the
game State meaning that you can run the
game headless without having to render
and then we do our rendering in um we do
our rendering typically in RB not
required if you want to figure out how
to do like a 3js front end for a 3D
thing that's totally fine the main
important thing is that you have a fast
uh fast State simulation
let me answer this guy real quick and
then we will uh we'll merge in The
Connect Four stuff we'll fix that we'll
perf test it and so on
I'm question how exactly does
compatibility work between C and python
dumb questions are fine uh look so this
is it's not hard and puffer's done a lot
of the work for you there
so this this is connect 4. Pi little
tiny file right this is the whole class
that you're seeing right here this is it
this is your python binding and you can
see that it adds this SC Connect 4 thing
here and then SC Connect 4 you have a
little piece of scon code that is the
intermediate layer between Python and C
it also does this Loop over many
instances of the environment so it makes
it very easy to efficiently run a whole
bunch of different instances of of the
environment uh on one lowlevel process
without having to go back to python
every time so this is all that's in here
very simple class the thing that is at
the top this is just header stuff
imported from
C and then after that literally you
don't have to think about it because
you're just writing you know lowl
procedural code here for the actual
simulation
itself and this works with everything
like this will work for multi-agent M
this works for all sorts of different
data types very very simple to add
bindings uh this is one of the things I
put a lot of effort into making clean
and simple with
puffer is the way that we handle these
things we also we make it so that you
can build the environment as a
standalone Inc as well so that you can
Dev stuff in pure C without having to go
through the really obnoxiously long like
Python compile and build tools and all
that that way you can just like focus on
building a low-l procedural game or
whatever and then The Binding thing is
like on top of it in separate um and is
you know there not really very many
places for error anywhere along
that and again you don't need to have a
ton of low-level Dev experience either
like I wrote python for 10 years the
low-l stuff is relatively new to me um
it's just it's not that hard is simply
the case like it's really not any harder
than writing these M's in Python
okay so let's look at this Connect 4 n
um I thought I had a c perf test in one
of
these I think I can just grab it from
the MOBA
maybe yeah we'll just grab this test
per how do you run just the H you don't
run the H you run the
C so you make a little C file like this
is the one right here this little tiny
piece of code for Connect 4 and then you
run
this you include the H for scyon so the
scon and python layer doesn't need the C
file it just needs the H the C is like
the Standalone in C which we use for
both building the web demo and for
testing
locally let's do like
this I'm going to make a perf test on
your Connect 4 real
quick equals
R
percent 7
ocean
local what's wrong here include time. h
build is the do c is what's used on the
website build yes got to get back to
work we'll look into this tonight
excited to find out more great yeah I'm
on Pacific Time and in the evenings I
will often hang out on the the voice
chat and Discord while I'm doing other
stuff so uh I help people out and get
people on there as well is there a list
of things that need implementing yes
check the uh the Discord see what is uh
interesting there there's like a status
report I just posted in the Gen chat um
and if you know there's nothing there
that's interesting to you like we will
find lots of other things we want to
build out a big library of games and
simulations and things of various types
here that's the goal
you it looks like there is a missing
include right
um okay it works now with standard D
that's
weird wonder why you need that header I
don't know
uh shift
exponent something's weird
here let me see if this is my screw
up I don't see where I would have broken
it this thing runs for
you it's kind of suspicious that that uh
that built for you at all actually did
you build it with the uh the like what
script did you use to build it did you
use the build ocean
stream uh where should I link him the
YouTube stream
all testing was via scyon python okay I
see so that's probably
yeah so typically what you're going to
want to do is and in fact it should be
easier to do it this way is you do the
testing in C um that will get you a much
much faster build time as well and it
will also get you things like um the
address sanitizer like C is very painful
to write without an address sanitizer uh
it's very very easy with the address
sanitizer right like here it looks like
we've got buffer overflows somewhere
here oops let's not do
I did try build ocean but it didn't work
on Mac
yes I have not tried it on
bit hold on something's weird let me
figure out what's some there's some
noise outside one
[Music]
sec all right it was just construction I
thought someone was breaking down my
door I have a script for that it has
different spags Flags Great yeah Spencer
if you want to add that script to uh the
build ocean I don't know if you can just
like add like a platform switch or
something that would be great this
debugging looks great would have been
helpful yeah I don't like making people
do painful work right like it should be
a lot easier should be U 64t for
column okay
are is this thing just an alias for like
a unsigned long by the
way now this thing has an exponent of
1785 so something's weird there possibly
hold on
I did I instantiate this thing with dumb
see piece width piece
height no you don't set anything else
locks
OBS
stuns these all look
fine these all look fine
yeah
ideally one thing I was confused about
when I tried to print F in theh file in
new infra it like holds off the
print did you forget a sln
Spencer did you forget like printa with
a sln at the
end rows and columns should also not be
int python build much more permissive I
don't know that's
weird um I'm surprised the python build
works
then I mean I can compile without these
flags and see what happens but I think
it'll
break I had a fast mode maybe I didn't
commit
that here this is a fast mode for
testing I needed to commit this
this will be useful for contributors as
well uh you just get rid of the F
sanitized Flags mind you that means that
you are not checking for
overflows and things like that okay this
actually does work so this is what
happens though this is what happens if
you uh you run it as is like it's
skipping all your moves and then this
thing is
purple so yeah there's some bugs to fix
here um
Jake do you want me to commit this how
about I commit you this perf test and um
do you want to see if you can fix it
from from here I'm also I'm happy to
debug this live if you get stuck on it
but would you like to give uh give it a
shot
first fascinating yeah this is how you
can test more
gotcha there you go so there's your
there's your easier test harness for
that uh let me know if that doesn't work
Spencer can you paste the uh the flags
for Jake
somewhere I don't have a Mac to like to
fix that
stuff oh cool ramy's doing stuff with
viz
Doom um if anybody has like questions
and like or is looking for a specific en
to be put on um would be a good time to
do that cuz otherwise uh until there's
more stuff to merge there's like a
rocket M that I could work on for a bit
uh there are a few other environments
that I might just start working on um
but I'd be happy to get people
onto stuff um the the key
so the key thing here and I posted this
status
report up here um pong is mostly good
breakout I'm going to go push some small
changes I'm going to go actually I
should grab my laptop and push that I
would like somebody to fix breakout it
needs some small fixes and uh Noah is
not going to have time to do it it's a
relatively small scope project for a new
Dev it just needs like some cleanup and
testing there's some stuff where like if
you hit the brick from the side the
check doesn't even isn't done so it'll
like clear all the bricks or something
um robocode is like a slightly more
midsize project that kind of just needs
one somewhat more experienced Dev uh not
crazy hard or anything uh to do it's a
port of a tank battle thing that used to
be used to teach people how to code in
Java ported it I did an initial port to
see and uh it just needs to be like
fully fleshed out and stuff but it's in
like a good starting spot uh triple
Triad needs a greedy opponent policy so
that we can have something decent to
play against multi-agent snake could use
a similarly small refactor probably like
pong but maybe even a little bit
easier
um let's see TCG is a bigger project so
if somebody's interested in like taking
point on the start of a bigger project
this one actually we have some academic
collabs on that are going to be starting
soon so this one would be really cool um
also if you have your own game M that
you're like hey I have this thing and
want to like bind it for Puffer that
would be cool as
well unfortunately on a construction
site and comp is dead so it won't be
able to send script okay well no
worries
um Jake you might have to Google a
couple Flags
also the cluster the cluster policy for
reference is uh once people start like
actually submitting substantial mdev and
want to be running like experiments on
stuff that's when you get uh you get
access to a cluster
machine that's the collab policy on
that thinking need to familiarize myself
with libraries and repos David here yeah
um I tried to make it very simple
Standalone stuff like if you if you want
to just get started adding an M or like
fixing up an existing M basically all
the code you need for the simpler ones
is a few hundred lines in a file so this
is the like this is the pong M that we
have you can see here this is the RL
agent playing pong versus this built-in
opponent the pong M itself is 300 some
odd lines a very simple procedural
python that is very similar to what you
would see if you were just writing this
normally as a game and not thinking
about reinforcement learning at
all and then the actual RL agent in here
is just grabbing uh this network from
puffer N.H which is is a uh 500 line
Standalone neuronet inference library
that I wrote that matches pytorch but
this is it this is the whole code that
runs on the web and we just compile this
to web assembly you can compile it
locally as well for
testing and we provide tools for that
puffer Li itself is a fair bit larger
but uh if you're just looking to get
started this is kind of a good spot and
then the idea is that like people write
M or people help polish up M and if they
want to get involved more in the
experiment and RL side I provide input
on that and I can show you how to like
start getting experiments running over
these
M even the more complic ated projects
that we have like this MOA this MOA is
still just one C file it's a 2,000 line
C file instead of a 300 line C file but
it's very simple procedural code like
you can read this thing top to bottom
and there won't be any
surprises is generally how I try to keep
the work around
cool lots of new potential contributors
that's
awesome we're really going to get this
project off the
great I guess while I'm in between
answering stuff here let me go get the
breakout en it's on my laptop at the
moment uh I'm going to take 2 minutes
put another put the kettle on for more
coffee or tea or whatever uh I'm going
to grab my laptop so I can sync up the
breakout code cuz I want somebody to be
able to clean that up and then I'll
probably do that and then start on some
more stuff with the rocket M uh in like
a couple hours once I finish all that be
right
okay so I uh I woke up early this
morning and immediately started
refactoring the breakout code on my
laptop um I'm going
to commit this up real quick and then
I'm going to start working on it on here
uh I'm not going to fully finish it cuz
hopefully one of you will take over that
refactor it's a pretty easy job for a
new
contributor
um
yeah hold
on let me Commit This real
minior get push origin
Dev get
P
push
yes
so this is now a very nice little
Standalone thing for somebody to
this okay so here's our breakout en it
actually has a train policy already
playing it you can see here you can hold
shift to take over for the
agent it's like up to fire the ball and
then left and right um but like this en
is very glitchy and there are just some
things that need to be better with the
code like the Collision checks right now
it you can like hit the uh the bricks
from the side and it'll like go through
a whole bunch of them basically it just
needs to be like polished up and made
into a slightly less exploitable game uh
it is a lot easier than the original
Atari Breakout as well I think that
that's kind of okay because the original
Atari Breakout game is really [ __ ]
like it'll just randomly slam the ball
back at you very fast okay yeah just
there you saw the puffer just kind of
like ate a bunch of blocks cuz the
Collision checks are bad so just a few
small things like that um it doesn't
show you the second screen of bricks in
the original Atari game there are two
screens of bricks so you get two levels
to clear it doesn't do that correctly um
and I don't think it resets cleanly when
you beat all the bricks as well that
plus minor code refactors so if anybody
wants to just take this on that would be
awesome
um
response looks good to me could start
working on breakout or Robo code awesome
yeah depends on your uh your level of
experience oh I missed your thing slime
volley hadn't thought of that game in
two decades yeah we would also be very
happy to have that as an EnV but it uses
like really janky old physics um it
would have to be either probably the
easiest thing would just to be to have
it do its own custom physics as like a
single file CNF um with rayb for render
uh we'd be very happy to have that one
if you want to do a new project we have
plenty of projects at the moment that
need to be finished if you want to take
the breakout one that would actually
just be awesome the robo code one is a
slightly larger project so depends on
your level of experience hold
on okay yeah you're very qualified for
this types of this type of stuff then so
yeah either basically if you want
something small to start with that's
just like a pretty simple little
refactor and like fix some weird buggy
Collision stuff you can do the breakout
it probably won't take you more than a
few hours and then uh the robocode one
is going to be like a probably few Day
project um for someone with decent
systems
background this is so great to have
people doing this stuff break out to get
the gears turning yeah I figure that
that's like a nice little contribution
and basically the way it works around
here is whenever people finish stuff I
will either review it on stream or in a
voice call in Discord either way as soon
as people are done with stuff in our
Frey glad I found your post so am I we
could really use the contribution help
like I kind of just got sick of stuff
this morning and just started tweeting
cuz it's like okay look this update has
just dragged on for too long because
there is only so much code that I can
write you know like I have to do the
core of puffer mostly myself I'm also
like trying to juggle all these
different environments and it's just
it's too much to do all of um and it's
an a Very scalable open- Source problem
right like these M's are basically
completely independent they're pretty
small and isolated they only take like a
developer per EnV to do
properly and I figured it's a good way
for people to get into the space as well
like I don't know Spencer joined a few
weeks ago and he already made he did the
Prototype well he did Connect 4 before
the rewrite that Jack just did he did
the Triad en and he's working on go now
already running experiments and stuff so
it's pretty easy to spin people up on
the RL side once they're doing
this yeah it's the best kind of parallel
embarrassingly parallel for the most
part occasionally I have to go in and
mess with like the uh the harnesses like
the bindings for these
M and I still have to do that manually
we're trying to cut down on boiler plate
and cut down on boiler plate there's
like a third of the boiler plate that
there used to be um there's still a few
things I think we could cut down a
little bit on the scyon but I have to
figure that out still oh did you say
wait
Cuda I didn't see if you had physics
background because we do want to be
doing more physics stuff at some
point lce yeah this
is that's some crazy
stuff heavy on computation Cuda M C++
okay well if you want to do physics
stuff um hold
on we've got uh I started working on
this earlier this week and I think
there's a UT Austin PhD student who's
also interested in helping with
gone
uh hold on let me show you this
demo is it just like d
i
where did my thing
go that's bizarre
let me get this thing to build real
quick because we've got like this rocket
Lander en that I
started un
2dh where did this thing go hold
on I could have sworn that
I I pushed like um bucks to D build
flags
weird let me find that so I I can show
in the meantime though the thing that I
uh we were building off of um it in
honor of of SpaceX Landing uh the crazy
rocket I found there's this rocket en
Landing en here that uh uses really old
janky python bindings for box 2D and I
ported it to C and I got it to be very
fast like a basic version of it this is
what it looked like in a python Port the
python Port was too slow but um
basically I've been working on this side
and I've been having a ton of trouble
figuring out the phys PHS uh the physics
side of this and the physics API with
box 2D and stuff um generally we do want
to have much better support for physics
types M's and yeah I just we generally
would like to have somebody who knows
that space and uh knows how to make that
stuff be
fast so if you're interested in that
side that's another thing we could
explore not sure if that's what you're
trying to get into or if that's what
you're trying to get away from either
way we're happy to have
just need
the source file shouldn't
I I have this let me go find where this
thing was so I can build the rocket M
and start working on that on the side
today I think that PhD student's going
to want to play with this m tomorrow and
it doesn't train
no hang on we'll have a cool rocket
Lander and in a
second I forgot the include
right yeah I I did this wrong so this is
duh you have to link this- I include
there we
[Music]
go okay so here's our very very basic
version of this rocket Lander en you can
mess with the rocket in all sorts of
ways physics is kind of
janky 2D physics engines have a bunch of
particular problems which honestly game
devs are more suited to than physicists
but I have a full tool belt of things to
try that's cool I mean we're not really
linked to um weird physics engines
either like I just was using this cuz
this was here I mean if you're going to
tell me that like hey this physics
engine ends up being like 10 lines of
math and we can just Implement like a
100 lines of code that's going to be
good enough for a lot of the physics
stuff that we are going to want to do
I'm very happy with that as well just
trying to get more open source
contributions under my belt and this
seems like a fun project yeah absolutely
and this is a very good way to get into
um Ai and RL space as well if that's
something that you're
interested in um because with puffer
it's actually pretty darn easy to get
these things to train now with how fast
it goes single body single platform yeah
10 Lin sounds right single body single
platform okay I
see the original end was a little bit
more than that they had
um where is it the original en had like
a little bit more stuff because
let me show you the
rocket I actually kind of think it's
funny to have a rocket Landing end
because it's like AI isn't rocket
science until it
is but um I mean it's obviously way
simplified so here they have like this
landing gear thing as well on it and you
can apply a force from the bottom and
you can also apply force from the top at
either side with these like
here the Falcon 9 is like seven years
old okay bet if you want mechazilla
Chopstick arms for landing rocket M pull
up and code it
Elon wants
them I mean it kind of worked the guy
wasn't wrong
[Laughter]
right crazy that it worked but it did
seems I mean he like like there wouldn't
be any he wouldn't get any respect for
the crazy things he does uh unless he
ended up being right most of the time
right that's the that's the hard part
you actually have to be
right otherwise you're just a
manager okay I don't know why I feel
like torturing myself with this rocket
Lander end right now but probably want
to do a little bit on it going to try to
fix breakout and let you know when I
have a PR up awesome I will be streaming
for the next probably 4 4 and a half
hours on this and then after that I'll
be uh probably in the Discord for like
an hour or so after
that that's the usual schedule
N I don't know if this is the updated
version of the N this uh this does not
feel like it controls correctly I just
tap the key once and it starts spinning
out of
control yeah I could have sworn that I
like I had fixed this portion here where
like the the actions weren't synced up
um that's kind of
weird that's no big
deal at least do we have the RL harness
for this yet in this
so now you just tap it and you can tap
it back like
this looks good office
hours bet is our resident Advertiser but
uh we do appreciate
stars on the
repository it uh it actually really
really helps to have stars on this thing
because it means that more people see
the project and we get more
contributions and we get more bug
reports and things like that so feed the
puffer
reward there's an out of bounds
penalty
[Music]
Blended Seven Ways to
Lander oh I think it's cuz I just
commented Out Hold
On The One obnoxious thing about this
rocket EnV is like um because it
includes box 2D it kind of complicates
the puffer setup a little bit so we're
going to have to figure out something to
do with that but for now we'll just mess
mess with it
locally okay so here we have a random
policy is controlling this
thing let's figure out with the reward
function of this
thing I did a whole bunch of stuff with
this reward that I don't actually
know if is a good
then also I'm happy to get people
onboarded with stuff and like working on
things um while I'm doing this I'm kind
of just working on this m in the
background in the meantime of stuff you
know oh this is awful these parameters
are just
awful uh
huh yeah this is very
[Music]
my head is covering
this okay so we should get a WP chart
for
sweeps okay so here's
our rocket Lander en and it can't
doesn't really learn to do anything
initially so I think that there's just
something wrong this is a very new
project and um like I've messed some
things up with
it it's going back
interestingly we'll see whether it
actually gets any better than this but I
will be interested to see what this
policy
does Discord
Jake will probably have a Connect 4 PR
at some
on BET do you have uh do you have Enduro
code for me to look at at some point
today or are you good on dev at the
moment seg
fault all right we had some work to do
there
worse Enduro is basically logically
there okay awesome
goal is to get more M's onto website
soon oh let me actually make a
cool nice little Enduro version nice
need to make it pretty as well yeah it
is somewhat important
not unimportant at
least um okay so our new experiment here
this is
crashing rewards crashing
here the goal with this is to just have
like some sort of rocket that does that
does a
thing so I can hopefully get a build out
that PhD student wanted to use it for a
demo at some point pretty soon
model
o
wouldn't mind helping with RL
integration not main ISS codes there
there are some C things not quite lining
up like what are you compiling with the
uh this F address sanitized Flags cuz
that should help a lot
yes it seems
fine like what is the actual problem
that you're dealing
couldn't diagnose with GDB either it's
very
weird I have to install torch yeah no
problem
very weird how
this so what I can't figure out here is
that technically it should just be able
to learn to not do anything and that
actually should give it decent reward
um I would like to at least have a
rocket that can like land itself with
some perturbations before we go crazy on
the physics
side just to like a
decent decent little environment you
know
um let me see I got to go print
out I'll print out
the reward obtained
okay so now you can see the reward
function
here I wonder if this is like that old
continuous reward
problem I bet you this is just a
continuous rewards being dumb problem to
be
honest what information does it have it
has the same information pretty much
from the original it knows its position
it's like its
velocities um torque stuff like that I
value do you want to just PR the N bet
because that just looks like bad setup
stuff
I don't mind having like half done M's
in the dev Branch it is a Dev Branch
after
all oh that's you trying to install
torch never
mind yeah okay you can fix your own
torch
errors yeah you can fix your own torch
errors let me fix this reward function
real
quick yo switch to Twitch what do you
consider to be a hard end for puff Ral
to
solve to solve most we've talked about
are considered super easy to Media to
implement and relatively easy to get a
decent policy
um
yeah so there are a
few Pokemon is hard but it's slow MOA
MOA is probably pretty hard that's like
a very complex environment um when we
finish the TCG the TCG will probably be
medium or hard um the secret M that I
have is probably also going to be medium
or hard uh probably hard Robo code will
probably be
mediumish um yeah the goal is to have
like a spectrum of M's right so like
easy would be pong and
breakout um maybe try it I don't know
how hard try it is to be honest it might
be hard Connect 4 might actually be
decently challenging once we have a good
opponent policy snake is probably pretty
easy
um MOA is definitely harder
right uh go is going to be harder go is
very configurable it can be easy medium
or hard depending on board size you know
there should be like a decent range of
different
complexities um things we're lacking on
at the moment we're definitely lacking
like enough continuous control style Ms
we definitely need more like continuous
M um and yeah
probably that's going to be the main
thing the problem with the the harder Ms
is like you need to find stuff that's
not going to take two months to
implement just one M right like the Moa
actually took like two months to do all
the stuff that was in
it and it's like it's a pretty decent
mob it has a couple render bugs um but
it's not like even a full a fullon mob
or anything right like you could spend a
lot of time improving stuff like the
Autos are actually automatic there's not
a way to do like a laning phase where
you have to go back and forth with Autos
it's kind of just like um you know team
battle simulator down mid at the moment
though probably there is potential to
learn like s side laning
this I guess we'll just have to
do we'll just paste it for
now X
why I want to change the way that the
rewards are structured this is I can't
believe that I made this error
again with the way that I made a
continuous
rewards kind of a noob
error I'm pretty sure that as soon as I
fix this it'll
work this is actually going to be an
instructive thing for people interested
in the RL side though so we have
rev
X rev y so the the key here is that um
if you give a continuous reward that's
just like the position or like the
distance from something it's actually
kind of hard to learn because if you
take a small step the reward only
changes a little tiny bit whereas if you
say you get a reward for going in the
right direction and a negative reward
for going in the wrong direction that is
much much easier to
learn so what we'll simply do
be going to be
previous hold on
want yeah it's cuz you want to go you
want to get closer to the center
okay and
then this next
one uh you want to get closer to the
bottom right so you want to
honest and then do we divide by I don't
think we have to should divide by as
much
anymore um this is probably only divide
by like a
thousand let's see if this does anything
so this reward
Y is not good I don't know why it's not
giving Us rewards
oh because this has to go duh this has
to go up
here yeah yeah yeah this has to go all
the way up
all right
now now you can see we're actually
getting positive rewards
right in positive rewards and now we get
Negative rewards for going up
going I think that the Thruster is done
incorrectly it should still be able to
optimize for this
though let's see if uh let's see if this
will actually learn anything now
tiny there we
go that's that's got some teeth to it
we're going to run a new
experiment and then uh we will see
uh I don't see anything that should mess
it up
learning let's see if we get WB curves
for uh this
rocket and folks I'm just kind of
chilling and deving on this in the
meantime um if anybody has questions on
like projects to get started on or
whatnot very happy to get people uh get
people going on
puffer okay so this is just unstable
right probably crappy hyper
uh oh
oh is probably
[Music]
good just going to set some things that
I know to be like generally
reasonable hyper
parameters we'll see what this gets
us there's kind of this little Quirk
with the way that carbs does hyper
parameter sweeps where it'll find like
these really decent learning curves that
are very
unstable we're kind of looking into
that oh this is
weird this rapidly gets even worse
are we still
unstable we're still very
weird did I mess something up oh yeah I
messed up totally the mini batch size is
horrible
again there we
go when you're looking at WB curves and
watching episode returns you assuming it
should be immediately getting better not
necessarily it's just taking a little
longer to figure out a tough State
action space so I'm looking at here is
these curves exploding these loss curves
exploding this is a diverging policy um
it's not like flat or anything it's
diverging um and I have I know that the
specific combination of hyper parameters
there is likely to cause that because I
had the mini batch set very very small
relative to the batch size meaning that
it's doing a ton of small updates on
stale data which can often be unstable
so I just switched that out and now I'm
going to see whether it's more stable or
other stuff is wrong here now a lot of
this work you shouldn't often have have
to be doing manually but because this is
a new environment and I don't know for
sure whether it is the environment
that's broken or the uh the training
here like the prams I'm doing a little
bit of it manually to get a sense for
things like it is suspicious that this
is still not looking particularly stable
here I give it a little bit longer it
looks
like n it's not really learning
anything this is a very simple problem
with a very nice reward so it should
basically learn instantly is the
thing
yeah they do something weird
n batch size is
one shouldn't this be
four oh no it should be uh it should be
two shouldn't
it yeah we
want probably this
okay so now the next question is going
to be why is this not
stable learning does not appear to be
particularly stable
you literally you get positive reward if
you just don't press
anything you get negative reward if you
press
up don't
you all right let's uh let's make it a
little let's make it a little simpler
up what if we do
this it literally has a button to press
and has to learn to not press
it I'm giving it a I'm giving it like a
very trivial task because basically if
this doesn't work it's very likely
something is like screwed up with the
data
somehow yeah so this is like this is
bizarre um this curve this is like
something fundamentally
screwy RL is actually pretty sane once
um you get stuff set up
correctly so
good okay we have a few things to check
here um so the first thing
eval eval a random
policy see what it
[Music]
does and it presses up too much I guess
right and then if I do it again with
this being off
it casually floats back down to earth
and gets good reward
right yeah start going up oh wait why is
it
Jank you see the reward being negative
here this uh this does not make sense it
should be getting positive reward right
now ooh do I not have the
file I guess I have not been rebuilding
the environment with the the python
version that would do it
to figure out how to do uh the Box 2D
include now aren't
I box
2D runtime Library do
include okay did that
work looks like
it now if I run eval do we get positive
reward yes we do get positive
reward so now hopefully we can actually
train it
right just double check one other thing
just make sure that this number here
prints out is positive
oh no because it's it's a random policy
that's fine
train and hopefully this should decrease
yep look at
that new reward curve
it literally was for once it was a
fundamental RL
thing it was a fundamental screw up with
the
uh with the way that we were specifying
rewards
cool we'll wait for this to Output a a
checkpoint of some
no we definitely support continuous
bases
is this
collapsing no it's just it's idling okay
this is good
this is going to be the world's most
boring policy to start
right so what we're going to do is we're
going to watch the policy back and it
shouldn't be doing anything so actually
ironically if it's not doing
anything uh then it is actually learned
correctly
because it literally just needs to drift
down to earth to start
with huh ironically it seems to have
found that it's able to just
spin
also reward can be
Amplified the more close it is like
interpolation also reward can be
Amplified there are many ways to set
stuff up
um I don't think that there's any reason
to have to do that like you don't need
to you should not need to increase the
reward the closer it gets it just needs
to have a reward for getting closer the
thing that I did before that didn't work
at all this actually works substantially
better by comparison though kind of
confused why it doesn't um
something I think I got my rewards
backwards seeing stuff from 20 minutes
ago oh yeah the uh the main thing that
was happening though before that was
preventing it from doing anything was
um the reward structure it's a very easy
to screw up continuous rewards you kind
of want to have rewards be expressed as
a Delta so like if I get closer I get a
reward not I get a reward based on my
distance it's interesting that it's
actually getting some positive reward
for what it's doing here probably means
I just have misspecified the reward more
than anything
but now we can uh we can build it and we
can play
it see doesn't actually show reward for
for
this we'll rebuild it and print the
rewards
out okay
so we're getting positive reward for
what we're doing
here gets negative reward if we do this
right
can see you're getting negative reward
by doing
stuff yeah it should be able to get
positive reward not just
negative but look at our train curve for
this
thing oh oh it actually look it got it
and then something
happened it got a a KL
Spike
interesting so they're actually it did
solve it and then it uh it got
destabilized somehow
interesting I mean I have what looked
like very stable
rewarding if the direction vector
is pointing to the
objective yeah you can do something like
that uh this is like debugging very
basic things here there are lots of
things that we can do better here um and
actually ironically this is a problem
where you're allowed to mess with the
rewards right because you're allowed to
make rewards based on like physical
orientation of the rocket like you would
be able to do that in the real rocket
problem
right that's very easy to
four I think that makes a
difference clip
Gamma and set this
to 10
mil 20
thing and see if it learns now and after
that we're going to give it a much
harder task
okay so this is going to train for a
couple minutes I'm going to go grab
myself a cup of tea and
um then we're going to actually make
this be the full task hopefully be right
[Music]
I think we should debug first before
sweep to see the physics that's what I'm
doing yeah that's what I'm doing here is
because just yeah the the solution is
usually to run a sweep but only when you
think that you have the environment
mostly figured out there's like a ton of
Jank physic stuff going on
here okay so what happened now
um there's like instability in learning
there's instability with physics there's
like lots of weird stuff going
on so this is what we just did
policy and it's not very
stable I don't know
why is it just like learning rate or
something do I have some dumb parameter
here that I'm not
seeing
48 a giant batch of
data actually do we even have a big
enough batch hold on this might be it so
was it 2 18 maybe yeah over
8192 so only 32 yeah this is kind of
small is this going to even slow it down
if I just do this
workers welcome YouTube
folks happy to onboard uh new people and
get new people onto projects or answer
questions or whatever while I'm doing
this kind of just doing this in the
background please do remember to start
the puffer repository it really helps us
let's see does anybody actually start it
today oh yeah it's gotten like an extra
like 10 15 Stars
today look at that nice little
uptick that's
great the only uh growth metrics I track
are stars on the repo and followers on x
I'm going to have to shift over to
tracking MMR mrr
eventually
um but for now we're kind of just
chilling the open source is
good so is it getting unstable here
what's going
on why does it get stuck around zero you
know
kind of weird how this policy
is I trained it at 260k so that's a nice
that's a nice speed bump at
least so we can actually run physic Sims
very quickly in fact I know we can go
even faster than that as
well why does it get stuck around here
it really I can't think of any reason
reason it should get stuck except that
the policy seems to become
unstable what would make the policy
unstable I could just be
hypers what
is it yes it theck roet just spawning on
the same spot and if the rocket goes too
far off the screen it gets
reset should be pretty
simple so I would like to see it solve
this like very easy
problem it doesn't even have to do
anything it just has to turn off all its
engines and gently drift to the ground
well it's possible the reward scale got
to be too
large for something this dense I doubt
it I mean I'll try this just in case cuz
this is quick
anyways oh and now would be a good time
to
still
negative is it
um let's see if it's more stable
n it's about the
same it's about the same as
before I don't like how these stats
explode like this it's kind of
weird right for this policy to be like
got a nice big batch of
data I don't see any parameters that
could cause instability
anything I'm trying to think what I
could be missing
this do I like is the learning rate just
massively too high or
something at least these experiments are
very
quick I have a couple things to do in
the meantime before I have to think too
hard about it
so many people we've got like 10
different people today they're all like
wanting to hop in
so so so so many people that's great
it's really really
great I mean for all of its faults X is
a really good platform for
organizing Tech
stuff
like literally just like got annoyed
this morning was kind of tired felt like
going on a tweet storm and now we've got
10 new people hopping into the Discord
and like asking for stuff to do gotta
love open
source did I forget to put a t bag into
this tea oh no I'm
good I think I forgot to put a new
teabag though hold on
i' like to stay moderately but not
ludicrously
caffeinated ludicrously caffeinated is
reserved for undergrad
students as a family friend of mine once
said you only have so many years to code
and eat ramen by the light of your lava
lamp
which I took literally enough that I
bought a bunch of lava lamps in
undergrad I had some great blunder
years okay so this thing is still not
getting positive reward somehow which is
very
odd um it's a very easy to learn
task let me see previous
says this is rewarding you based on
distance from previous yeah this is
insane isn't it hold
um actually no I this is correct isn't
it you get rewarded for decreasing the
magnitude of X or
Y
yeah so this should be fine
um things that bother me are the
stability of the training
runs but it really should be able to
solve something like this like this is
very very
easy
um curious how it gets to nearly
zero as well
that I actually and I saw it Spike up to
like 30 or something as
well it just wasn't
stable there a reason that it wasn't
stable
oops I do this this reward like this
extra reward messing with it somehow
good
progress oh
loss a value loss gets
learned
zero trying to think what it is that's
getting
stuck around
model that definitely shouldn't be
getting positive reward
hold on I think that there's probably
something that I'm not understanding
with like the
rotation let me just see real quick if
this works if this doesn't work then
there's something seriously
wrong literally just has to learn to not
engage
learning is this like entropy screwing
us over or something
I'd be surprised if something that small
if the entropy coefficient that small
was messing with
there's like something that I'm missing
here it gets reset on
and that's just one step it really
shouldn't make a difference
what visualization methods do people use
to track training Behavior there aren't
any man you log some metrics and you
watch it play the
environment this is one of the reasons
that we like games so much is because
they are visually
interpretable I mean the thing that's
going to happen EV here right is
like we're going to have a whole bunch
of M that are super fast and that we
know are good so if you mess with your
algorithm you know you're going to be
able to know for sure whether you just
broke your training code or something
fundamental because you're going to be
able to train on known good environments
incredibly
quickly right now in RL we have known
good environments but they're very
slow the ones that are fast are very
very simple like even simpler than pong
and breakout for the most part people
have like these really really dumb
simple
s I'm not going to spend all day doing
this Z is not that that
important but I would like to get
something
whoops
okay it would be nice to have a
physics of some
it's just very high
frequency hello could I ask an unrelated
question is spinning up still the go-to
resource for beginners I know RL Basics
want to review by actually making things
looking for grid World cart pole stuff
to start yeah puffer is the place
probably for that um cuz we have some
M's that are like very fast our pong en
I think our pong en is probably a good
one to train right let's say
my train back
native okay let's just train pong live
for
you we've got a little CNN lstm type
model
here and do our stats not
work I think our stats should
sparse okay so there you go 35 seconds
and pong is
solved
right oh no no no no it isn't my bad
this is episode reward okay I forgot I
uh we haven't tuned it yet so the hyper
parameters are terrible I'm sure we will
solve it in 30 seconds because we've
basically done that before
um hold on pong has a really weird
learning
curve you'll
see okay so here's this rep episode
return here's episode
score pong has like this takeoff curve
with learning
now apparently I broke it with one of
the updates that's obnoxious which is
very weird because we actually have it
deployed on the website
um I'm trying to think should I try
breakout
instead I'm could do
breakout I did also just mess with
breakout
recovers yeah there it goes okay it
recovered
so we don't have amazing hyper
parameters tuned for this thing um but
I'm just training this locally on my
desktop here
and I guess it wasn't very stable this
run let me find you something better so
if you wanted to literally train cart
yeah so there's like some little hitch
here otherwise it would have gone
straight um here's cart pole being
optimized I think like 100 or 200 or
whatever is the intended target so
cartpole you just solve it very quickly
no problem
there remaining 30 seconds okay we'll
just let this train and then we'll show
you the policy if that rendering
Works
70 very helpful did not no scope of
puffer so the fun thing with puffer is
like you see me running this command
like this just to train but um it's not
like sb3 the code is very transparent so
you can actually see all the training
code very very easily and find where
everything is and how everything works
it's not meant to be a black boox thing
it's yeah so
mode
eval you see I got the ARG wrong and it
tells me that it gives me all the args
that you that are valid I just wrote it
wrong okay and here's cartpole here's
the model that we just
trained now now pong should literally
train in the amount of time that I
showed you before um we haven't done a
proper sweep I guess on that that's kind
of
embarrassing Let's do let's do our
breakout let's see if I didn't break
that all these Ms are in Dev right so
like the new ones are uh not always the
most
stable that's one of the things we're
trying to get all these contributors to
help us
fix but breakout I think should at least
have a consistent learn
curve okay yeah so here we
go come on
there we go yeah there we go now it
takes off
um
just okay so now this is training
breakout
live and we actually have the policies
deployed online for these like the
pre-train policies
so you can actually watch the agent play
Breakout this is one that we trained
before it just plays in your browser
this is running live in your browser as
well like the network as well is just
running
locally we also have the pong
one this is if you actually train the
pong with you know better hyper prams or
whatever and we have some other things
as
well so lots of M's
there going to be more M we could
definitely use help with them uh
spinning up is plenty of math it's a lot
of math um I actually posted I posted on
X just
yesterday I posted my guide for new
people in
RL which is already more than you need
to even start contributing stuff but I
posted this there's also a part two on
my my X account
in the track Mania video I like how they
display multiple agents and watch them
evolve I know this only happens post
training yeah I mean if we if we have
people that want to help us make cooler
visualizations that would be great
yeah we definitely need better hyper
prams for our simple M's cuz like our
breakout and our pong should both be
solved in under 30
seconds ML Class use BAU Confident come
up to speed just getting caught up
tutorial hell with making stuff in
Python dependencies yeah so here's the
thing with puffer right um what you do
is you use our Docker and then you never
have any problems ever
again we have puffer tank it's pre-built
as an image so it's literally just going
to be the download time of the image you
like switch to the dev Branch or
whatever if you want to contribute stuff
and then all the dependencies are
handled and you don't have to deal with
that stuff dependency Management in
Python is
terrible and you have active support
available in the Discord
also um I will tell you that like if
you're doing all this course stuff it's
good to learn things but like you
probably actually have more than enough
um like background to actually be doing
productive work already um people will
be surprised to know I never read an RL
textbook I also didn't ever take an RL
course they didn't exist when I was um
you know doing my undergrad and stuff at
the time there were not any courses I
guess there were some books still um but
for the most part I read a bunch of
papers and I did a bunch of
RL and yeah there's some Theory stuff in
there right that's kind of important but
also like half the time in RL you like
make some weird approximation to the
algorithm and it ends up just being
faster and better um RL is a heavily
heavily empirical
science so yeah I don't know I would
just I would generally suggest people
just like getting involved and helping
with this stuff cuz like the reason that
RL is in such a bad place at the moment
is just purely because we never built
fast and easy tools environments and
infrastructure so that's what I'm
approaching at the
moment like actually my playbook for
most of my Dev it's 80%
engineering 15% like basic scientific
method experiments and stuff and May
maybe 5%
math so really I mean the main thing is
just for people to like start getting
involved in like um you know taking on
little environment projects shipping
environment
code as soon as we get a big enough
repository of like very nice fast and
stable environments the whole field is
going to just be completely revamped
revamped because you're going to be able
to get comprehensive experiment
results across like 10 different
environments on one GPU in a day that's
something that you cannot do at all at
the moment in RL so you can be a lot
stupider about how you do things when
things are just fast enough for you to
run all the experiments that you'd ever
things where's this rocket Lander in
that's giving me
grief it's so weird that this is
not oh wait yeah yeah we actually just
came up with a a thing here on this
right let me see
what if I do like this oops one over
10 then I do 24 sub steps do this work
okay so now the m is way faster it's
actually funny that that feels
mean you called me puffer I am honored
yeah I thought I did that but I wasn't
positive dude I swear I just like I fill
my head with so much crap doing all like
the Social Media stuff for puffer and
all the dev and all the reviews and
stuff I just end up cooking my brain
halfway through the
run I've been doing um I think I did
like a
924 paac is 5K this morning
I don't know I haven't been going fast
too fast with the runs lately because
it's mostly a strength
block now 924 is considered quite
back yeah the running is not not too
fun fitness very important
though next goal is going to be 1,000
total and then after that it's going to
be th total and be running a
marathon because I'm slightly under
Marathon shape at the
moment I'd have to do like um maybe five
six week block to get back get my uh my
endurance back to from like half
marathon to Marathon
distance got to keep at
it okay I'm just why does this thing not
work like okay here hold on
if
I okay here we have our rocket Lander M
now
okay okay here's our rocket Lander
end it's kind of crazy how long the
Horizon is on these t tasks right like I
think the reward function is just shitty
like you just take one action you press
the key once and you see it shifts your
reward for like the next 30
I don't think it's anything fundamental
with the algorithm actually
idea what if I did
this is this like bat [ __ ]
crazy last question is now you can ask
questions steering llm Behavior via RL
kind of within the culture fit for
deing V so not really and let me tell
you
why the side of RL that I'm approaching
at the moment right the side of RL that
we're looking at is high throughput
simulation anything to do it's not just
games either right anything that you can
simulate fast so virtually get unlimited
data the reason this is what we're
looking at is because it's a very
underinvested area of research it's one
that's likely to be important for
long-term progress in AI because there
are a lot of problems that don't mesh
well with LMS where you do have lots of
data uh and it fundamentally scales in a
way that is different from llms like you
end up using tons and tons of data with
not much compute and not many parameters
versus llms that end up using a ton of
Compu and a ton of parameters with not
much
data um I do think that there is a place
for llm with RL like a tie-in but the
key for that is going to be you're going
to have to have a small policy that the
LM is mostly letting do the work and
then once in a while when there's like a
highle decision to be made then the llm
can take over the work a lot like how
I'm not actively thinking about where
I'm moving my hands and stuff right now
it's kind of just like
automatic you want RL to take the
automatic portion
um yeah that's kind of the main area
that's going to be like a future
research thing but at the moment we're
mostly looking at High throughput Sim in
that area of things which to be fair is
an area that you can actually make a
difference in without having to have a
gigantic
cluster Iceberg video should be a very
good primer on RL and where I see the
field going and such it's exciting to me
because this is a space where there
really aren't a lot of people doing this
stuff so like this literally will not
get done um if I don't do it in puffer
so tremendous chance for impact on the
science of it and also you can do this
stuff at pretty darn low compute
resource scale um pretty much anybody
can just like code up an interesting
environment and immediately
contribute massively to the
field which is very cool to me
ah
okay
so I'm curious to see if this is going
to work just you know for the sake of it
cuz this would tell us something
siphon this is probably going to be
crazy slow as
well just recompiled again as a shared
Library
yeah oh just got build ocean script
working on Mac this is much
faster should
be really should
be I try to make things easy on
y'all I'm really looking forward to
merging that end of yours as well uh
Nathan I'm super excited about that
all I have to do is I have to not play
it so much that I decide to download
dopus again that would be
tragic that would be a tragic end to
puffer
[Laughter]
[Music]
lib should F sanitized detect things
that are not
freed or only seg faults it'll detect um
out of bounds access on arrays and stuff
they're a bunch of different flags
this would be impossible without puffer
lib well I do what I
can be the
no more
contributors that's fine we got quite a
bit out of that
Holy getting really addictive now that
I've added animations oh
gosh uh
I already have 3,000 hours in that game
I do not need any more hours in that
game
I don't know when you stopped playing
Nathan but I'm pretty sure I
like I forget what it was I think I
soloed coriander on a Level 174 any in
like masto or something insane like
that I don't
know I went nuts with that game
how confident am I that it's the reward
shaping that's the problem
learn yeah yeah this should definitely
learn
fundamental RL
[Music]
screwups starting to have so many ideas
for games
now yeah you can kind of just add
whatever um I mean we have room for all
sorts of different contributions in
puffer to be honest right now like more
games is good control stuff and physics
stuff is good industry Sims are good and
actually for like science type people uh
I have a project in mind there as well
that's going to be like still building
M's but much simpler M that's going to
be heavier on the science side like I've
got all sorts of stuff for people
depending on where people want to jump
in
like the future of RL is going to be
very very
bright the biggest thing though right
now like in the short term in my mind I
really want to ship 1.1 as an official
update like as soon as possible ideally
I'd like to ship it in the next couple
weeks before I go back to Florida um
which means having like the 10 stable
environments and baselines and all that
stuff it's just God so much work
work okay seriously what is wrong with
these
like bothering me that I can't figure
out why this is so
screwy like this one shouldn't be that
complicated I wouldn't
see okay you know what we're going to
do we're going to be a little more
pragmatic about this
we're going to just see if we can train
it to learn a single fixed action
because I think that there's a bug
time
on what did we set this to
something yeah something's definitely
screwy
here oh I wonder if it's the same bug
from before
actually that'd be real embarrassing
wouldn't
it hold on
oh
wait I mess up
massively I messed up massively didn't
I I messed up massively hold on I found
it yeah this is guaranteed it
actions rewards look
good so why
yeah I will fix this thing
even if it ends up being something very
silly I hate how this uh automatically
indents for
zero I I really don't care if this makes
me look stupid like I'm I'm going to
find this stupid bug and I'm going to
fix it it's going to be some dumb data
thing
okay I mean one of the reasons I am so
incredibly insistent on the RL code
bases being like simple simple simple
simple including the like the
environments including the training
including everything is because RL is
kind of cursed and stuff will go wrong
and it will go horribly wrong like you
do not want to be waiting through five
layers of fang
abstractions in RL you just don't it's
not a good time trust me
one all right there's more stuff to find
here I'm going to be right back grab
more tea use the restro and then we're
going to fix this um do we have anything
else toly to
page that guy need some assistance uh I
think he was asking for like a
substantial feature for stuff I'll be
right back
though
funny it made like some react app that's
so silly
wait it actually went up it trained
more that's
bizarre let's figure out why
okay rocket
[Music]
Lander oh it's cuz literally nothing
happens question
mark That's
render FPS
oh wait we didn't I messed this up
didn't
I okay so here we have rocket Lander
which is constantly resetting
transform
Y is
uh how's that make any sense where do I
start
it where's the initial position
initial
y it's 500
scale oh is it just just like launching
it I'm
confused let's
zero thank you to bet our resident
advertising
here most amusing bet do star the puffer
star the repo helps me out a lot
okay so somehow this transform is
completely
how how is it
120 reset
why is this transform like
so messed
weird am I just not understanding
something about how
um how this physics engine works or is
it just glitchy or like what
pause so when you step
this did I mess up the step function
hold
on I'd really just like to have this
working today because
um there's somebody who hopefully is
going to help on this over the weekend
and I'd like to have um a basic demo I
don't want to just be fighting with
something totally cursed I mean the
really the goal is to just have this
thing just do something basic today and
then also maybe fix up the rendering so
it looks kind of
cool I should be able to get it done if
I don't get just stuck on this all
day and it's really kind of
silly there rocket Lander
was all in
C oh do I not have any of this
committed I should probably do
that let's commit up all code real quick
oh was it one over oh I know what I know
what it is I'm just dumb okay
okay I remember rocket Lander that's
what I'm doing right now is I'm trying
to fix that
project
normal just
falling now balls very
slowly and make it yep
I'm so
now get rid of these print
up and we can run the sanity check to
see if it actually can learn to just
like press a button or if I have
something fundamentally wrong with the
the bindings
high well actually now it learned kind
of yeah so why wait why the heck was
that so
and the fact that the value loss is so
messed up
1 and then you pass float
actions which is num
M's by
three and then you call
step made some progress on connect por
you on
Linux behavior is very different on Mac
OS which is
annoying that's very odd it's really
should not
be perf test running on my Linux box but
train seg
heading to bed now though okay we can uh
we can look at this whenever you're next
free uh I have some common checks on
stuff like that to look
don't think I can make progress might
need help debugging scon layer submit a
PR and then I'll check it whenever I
have time
to just submit a quick PR I'll just Auto
merge it and uh I'll look at
break I don't know what the heck is
wrong with this
crazy rocket end
here seems to
work these are normal leaks that's fine
test looks good
500k uh and you also you're not
compiling this in fast mode mod either
so you're actually it's 500k on slow
mode probably way faster on fast mode
huh a dress sanitizer takes a lot of
time apparently not in this case that's
very weird never seen that
immediately unless this didn't
compile
see works for
you looks like it
weird yeah just like I can run it and
play
it I'm kind of curious to
see what was this thre mil
this train is very
slow so I'm actually suspicious as to
whether it's compiling
four hold on I'm a little suspicious
because uh it doesn't seem to be running
as fast as it should be it's like
running with like the speed of the old
version or something
like
I 20
time
try oh well hold on should be two and
M doesn't appear to be quite
fast but
uh say 48% M
time faster on my
now trying to figure out here let's do
cuz I'm not sure that this is actually
being compiled
correctly going to do print F
compiling yep it is compiling so we're
running the right
kind of suspicious the M
Speed doesn't seem to matter how you
I guess we're just dropping perk in the
scon layer or something
and of curious
uh how this
does what's it like score of one is
solved
good okay so it should be able to get a
score of one
so it just save
checkpoint 85% win
rate I'll let this run until it saves
checkpoint 150 and then I'll watch
it interestingly it looks like it's
stuck it's stuck just below 90% win rate
maybe oh no
what my connect
for
eval made of
uh I think it's actually winning
right did it figure how to exploit the
model or is it just that
good I see a lot of similar
games is it always the same game it's
not always the same
game no it's not always but yeah this
thing is kind of good isn't
see I'm going to wait for it to finish
training the 100 Mil and I'll ship it to
the web as well why
not then you all can see if you can beat
it we can ship uh we ship a model real
quick it's a shape
it's a shame you can't play versus it
well I think what we're going to do is
we're going to we're going to let you
watch the RL agent play against the
scripted opponent and then you can play
against the scripted opponent so you can
take over for the bot to see if you can
do any
better we could also flip it around so
that you play versus the neural
net neither of these are very
hard you'd have to strip out the
scripted we just make a flag right that
just overwrites the action or
whatever not a big
deal all right
so let me show you the process let me
show you how easy it is to like add a
model into pure
ciments Connect
4 956
model
382 uh let's see connect for
weights
PT going to
be or
okay so now we have this
model
um config
[Music]
ocean oh it's literally just playing
with the default policy and it's still
able to win that's kind of
weird okay
really need to sleep yeah go sleep man
you wake up to a nice model online that
you can play
with thanks for this thanks for the
contributions
we can chat up weekend Monday Tuesday
whenever see
you all right so we don't have model
code in here at the
uh wake up to a model lady model every
day
please do star the repository it helps
out a
rabbit Swift
what how's it going
nice I'm trying to think how how I want
to do this little bit of code right
default so it's 42 and then action space
is
seven believe it's like 42 and
7 okay and now what we actually have to
do is
upper. num agents
perfect so uh we're just going to
make uh default
net default
default okay and then this is going to
take was it linear
encoder actor value function I think
there a couple relu
maybe me
see encoder
is encoder
re and then decoder
oh it's just
decoder it's just uh linear Rel
linear and then multi-
discreete multi-
agents input Dam make linear make Rel
make linear value function multi-
discreet actually very
easy input Di
I don't know why it said this is hidden
dim this is action
dim input
dim
oh
yeah hidden
dim input hidden action we can even
do then value function
goes hidden dim to action dim I believe
and then multi
discreete make
multi discret is logic
sizes action
right we just make
a
default to do a free
function
OBS coder yep we free
everything and then a
forward for
default linear
REO linear
linear actor value function okay so we
should actually be good
we all we do need to know
the size of this
network so what we will
do okay 60 this is a Tiny
Network
six tiny little net
Doh too few arguments to make default
uh I believe we have 128 Default hidden
observations expected float argument is
of type unsigned
Char uh fair
enough so
we'll have to
do
float
in and then we'll just do observations
an
address let's
see what other stuff we have to
sh make default
here we pass
[Music]
in a linear
layer right oh I don't know
why this is
dumb why did it do this
perfect okay now we just have argmax
things
it we get an
overflow on the multi discret okay
that's
deserved yeah that's deserved
go now we have a thing that runs but
it's clearly not running the correct
thing
default what did we provide we said One
agent 42 input 128 hidden and
correct calic num agents times the input
dim
yeah and then we do this in make
linear input to Hidden this is the
encoder make Rel with the hidden
dim and the actor here goes from hidden
dim to action
dim and then value
function di to
one and logit
sizes is what we do
here and this is actually already
looking
fine and then what do we do we
do linear
on
OBS and and then we re and then we actor
and then we value
function well we can soft Max multi-
discreete no reason not to think that
changes anything
right
okay and then we have what soft Max
soft Mac takes int not unsigned in is
that
it so this actually should be
int expected int but it's getting
unsigned in
is I thought I know what the problem
was why is this uh
I have no idea why this
is scy here because this should be
oh I see this is just a static yeah this
is fine we'll just do
this that's such a really like a
ridiculous warning as well
instar okay does this actually work is
the question after all
that oh yeah
and then what do we have to do
here we
do sleep or
something
maybe if I hold shift
I can take over I think
right I don't
know it just let Blue
win I'm
confused I don't I just win if I press
here yeah I do if I do put it in three
okay so like I
like
they this is not an allowed
all
right so at least I got uh I got that
integrated we'll have to go back to the
rocket I think for a bit I'll leave this
up for a second I'll be right back the
okay couple Twitter people I think more
contributors be live for another hour or
two
anyways as well drop some
replies oops
I thought we had comments or
something I missed something
there that's what I was that's what I
was
uh I can never tell which of these
accounts are
where I mean I yeah he follows
uh he follows uh puffer stuff because I
mean I do I'm doing all this stuff in
rayb I've always said like I since I
found the platform rayb is amazing it's
an amazing
project I don't see him usually asking
for donations to stuff
I think usually the best way uh to
support him is to
uh in
Discord wait what wait where is
there did I miss a
bot wait is there a is there like a scam
bot impersonating somebody in my Discord
okay oh on his Discord maybe yeah no I I
think the best way usually to support
him in his work is to just buy some of
his paid tools okay yeah yeah I think
the best way to support his work is to
just buy some of his paid tools like he
has a few uh a few things that he sells
that are really really good like do I
have it here
yeah like right here um I mean look at
this thing this is just beautiful
like look at all this like he's got like
all sorts of nice stuff in here it's
like super super
snazzy you can like get some of his
stuff to
support was a little bit crashy on
Windows but uh I will say that the UI
and everything it's like ah I wish all
software was built that way it's so
responsive and fast and clean it's like
perfect he makes really good stuff can't
possibly speak well enough of of
RB what
that's
hello all right
um good with Connect 4 for
now let me see where I was with
this this ridiculously basic rocket M
that's not
working like this should be able to
learn instantly just the the sanity ch
back forgive us our trust
what oh are
you are you the guy that I muted
earlier nap time Gramps or
somebody I I muted you because I thought
you were a troll uh I'll gladly unmute
you if it was like an honest
unmute there you
go yeah so here's the thing with this
right
like there are a lot of people that kind
of Brigade on the uh the chat GPT stuff
like I use language models but like I
don't use them to write all the code for
me right like it's not actually a 10x
boost for any experienced developer it's
like you get maybe 30% on uh it's
essentially a typing buff for most use
cases and then um it's really nice for
like new libraries and stuff that you
haven't learned like like documentation
essentially and stuff um for stuff
you're not familiar with
but uh yeah it's really not like a 10x
thing there is a lot of just marketing
hype coming out of open aai these days
um I mean I was there for a while it's
the best place I've ever worked at least
it was when it was a smaller company but
like yeah there's there's a whole bunch
of marketing stuff like the models are
legitimately getting better and they
have so much random domain expertise at
this point that yes occasionally they
can produce very good insights but they
can't do so consistently yet that will
probably get better the thing that I'm
less certain about is whether they're
actually going to be doing autonomous
research um a really good way to see uh
autonomous like if if an agent's
actually going to be able to have
autonomous capabilities see if it can do
any sort of like mediumsized software
project right cuz like even a really new
Dev can do like a medium-sized software
project and iterate and learn when stuff
goes wrong where a lot lot of these
models they'll just get stuck in a loop
and they're clearly not problem solving
quite in the way that people are yet and
I think it's probably architectural with
the way that they're trained and
actually that's something that I think
my work might help with is fundamental
interactivity training interactively so
yeah there you
go it doesn't quite iterate in the way
that you would think bet though it's not
like I can't give it like one of these
environments hybrid maybe but yeah I
can't give it like one of the projects
that I'm giving to new contributors in
puffer and have it do it it just
won't you're good though no worries no
heart feels
the thing that I'm like the one area
that I'm very much down on llms is I see
a lot of newer devs like trying to use
llms to code for them without learning
how to code like llms are now a tool
that you can use to learn how to program
better and be more effective like you
don't want to use them to replace
thinking for you that like really
irritates me right like having this
thing and using it to think less rather
than using it to think more effectively
that's like the one spot I get just so
irritated cuz that's just like that's
some dystopian Futures [ __ ] right
there you
know like the cool thing is now L like I
would love to be able to
learn like learn any field very very
quickly at an expert level without
having to go through like multiple years
worth of training and whatnot right like
that's something that could happen I
don't want these things to like oh I
guess I don't need to learn about
physics anymore
right really bad at thinking I mean
eventually I AI will be better at it but
I do hope that even then people still
use these things as ways to think more
rather than to think
less big grop update
xmus is that one hold on are you at X or
you just
ring I don't know anything about
that grock's
cool I mean they only got started pretty
recently on language model side I'm yeah
it'll probably get substantially better
as
well trying to think I can train this
thing
so what we're doing at the moment is I
have this uh this rocket Lander en I
mean here you go Falcon 9 based on in
honor of uh the recent rocket stuff uh I
found this old en where is
it yeah here it is there's this old
rocket en and it's really slow because
it's in Python so I'm trying to Port
this stuff to C and get this working
with RL and it's kind of just being a
pain I'm work on it but it's being a
real
pain grock better than GPT after
Christmas
maybe elon's usually right longterm he
sometimes misses on the time predictions
so I don't know if it'll be better after
Christmas or it'll be better like you
know in a couple of years or whatever
we'll see
I think it is likely they'll do pretty
well there are a couple weird things
with their Tech stack um and a couple of
The Hires that they made are a
little wow I don't want to go into too
much there but
like there are a few ways that could
potentially go
wrong I think that they probably just
win on distribution though because it's
literally it's in it's directly in X so
they're probably just win on
distribution
alone even if it's not quite as
good I know people realize they can
cancel their chat GPT subscription and
just keep their
Twitter but that's less interesting
right that's like it's less interesting
than making better
[Music]
TR saves folks 4 100 bucks
yeah I don't know I would
I'd frankly I'd be quite happy to stop
financially supporting open AI with all
the uh the
regulatory capture
bit I mean they still some really
awesome people there though I will say I
think Alec is still there a couple other
people I
triggers
are
teachers I don't know about
that se
that random saying I mean it's like a py
saying that doesn't really hold up like
if you think about it it doesn't really
make sense does
buttons very
weird our triggers are our
know sometimes things irritate you
because you're being stubborn but
sometimes things irritate you because
they're just stupid
GPT uh no it's not language models are
good it's like the
marketing uh and the Zeitgeist around
them that bothers me more than
anything like we had um like all the nft
Bros and like cryptos scammers kind of
moved over to AI when AI got big and
like I would just I would like those
people out that would be nice because
like we're trying to do legit science
and engineering here
right kind of just like
bches what we're trying to
do no marketing doesn't bother me
marketing that's not exactly honest
bothers me
good you're going to have to try harder
than that if you're
trolling non-engineers bother you no
dishonest dishonesty bothers me
and I'm answering
questions okay I mean if you I couldn't
tell it's like you don't exactly get
tone over text but
dishonest
okay uh I don't think it is
inherently doesn't have to
work hold on if I
do no it's the train setting was fine
well bad marketing can be dishonest
marketing can be effective and honest
effective and dishonest can be
ineffective and honest it can be
ineffective and dishonest right
M's this is what I use for everything
else though
yeah I'm mostly trying to figure out how
to get this m to
mean it could just be that it takes
absolutely forever to train
this marketing fails and Company
fails yeah I'm not going to philosophies
too
much
like I mean I'm a researcher first and
foremost
my goal is to push
forward um this
Tech by the means that I have available
to
me which are mostly developing puffer
organizing people around puffer getting
people developing more environments
getting people developing more
experiments providing what resources I
can this sort of a
thing I mean the only real marketing I
do is like the type of stuff I post on
uh on X where I mean as you can see I'm
mostly just talking about the stuff I'm
building a puffer is technically a
company but the thing is all the stuff
is open source and that's the priority
right the priority of my with my work is
to push forward the science so there is
a business side but it's a very minimal
business side and uh you know the
priority
oops the priority is pushing forward the
tech because I think it's important that
this Tech be developed
work it likes works well enough that I
don't think there's something
fundamentally
broken but not well enough that I'm like
confident in it it's really weird it's
this really weird in
between I mean I'm like
or just decrease the batch size or
something
like really doesn't
make sense to
me but the task is literally learn to
press it's a sanity test literally it's
just if you press this button it's bad
don't press the
button build a
team that is kind of what I'm doing with
open source right we've had I've had 10
people message me today wanting to
contribute stuff to puffer and uh I've
been onboarding
people no full-time hires until um later
on in puffer when eventually I have uh
you know a good chunk of
revenue for now mostly just building
stuff we got
spells when do you want when do you want
me to sit down and help you integrate
this Nathan oh
sure yeah that's I'll gladly try it
Nathan you can PR if you want I'll help
you integrate whatever you want that
that's awesome uh no no product ASAP the
only product that puffer sells is uh we
sell extended support on puffer so if
you're if you have a company that needs
priority features in reinforcement
learning or extended support around the
stuff that we do then that is something
that you can be uh that you can pay for
but that's the only near-term product
mostly this is about the research and
the science
here you can upload it in 5 minutes but
disclaimer I didn't free any
okay use case for normal people nope
it's not a businesses to customer thing
it's um reinforcement learning is used
for a wide variety of more industry
problems and also it's important I think
for AI progress as a
whole didn't free any array it's
whatever hold on I'm just this is
driving me nuts
yeah okay I should take a break from
this it's just it bothers me because I
really want to get like a little
training demo because I've got this PhD
candidate who's going to want to work on
this thing tomorrow and I want it to not
be
cursed this is a huge
contribution this is awesome
happened okay that's
fine and
then
Coco oh is
this just
testing okay
I think I can merge this and it won't
break
H wait
what oh Sho wow
going I mean this is a crazy this is
going to be the biggest code
contribution we've
well I mean no his it's reasonable that
his environment is that long it's a
complicated
environment have you read his code
already
okay and did you add the
setup I don't see setup.py
modified doesn't this need a setup. pi
um wait Nathan you need a separate
compile
path be a trivial matter for you guys to
make a consumer facing service not
necessarily not everything is uh not
everything is naturally B
Toc no RL net gotcha
in fact the vast majority of AI stuff is
B2B uh F may not be used without shared
[Music]
interesting I why is that needed that's
kind of weird
wow this looks
good
holy
rabbit is this a
buff oh my gosh this is it turns you
into a tofu
science so there are
companies that internally use
reinforcement learning for a variety of
different things reinforcement learning
is very
hard we have there have uh there are
very poor tools for it there are very
few ways to test it and make sure it's
working well and there are very few ways
to generally get it working on your
problem we make that
easier is there a pass button yeah there
is okay and you made it so that you just
control both players for the time being
yeah the AI for this is going to be
scripted opponents for this is going to
be pretty hard I imagine right
Nathan triple explosive
SEO that's pretty
cool don't make excuse I don't know what
you're on about man
what yeah it is hard I'm making it
easier I'm provably making it easier too
cuz all my code is
online the animations are very fast I
assume there's like a time scale
difference thing is don't know what this
is ask Nathan Nathan made this uh MMOs
PVP
simulator that's freaking
awesome we're going to have to integrate
this on the RL
side man this is going to be hard as
well to integrate but this is an awesome
awesome
Sim yeah bet set is fair I don't really
care I'm kind of just chilling
I'm used to pointed
questions what do you think a PhD is
about I see how you did
uh I see why you did these specific
spells as well you've got like MP effect
you've got uh out of line of sight
you've got you know inline of sight
checks you got a buff I see you did like
a rep representative like craw move set
type thing uh the HP does go negative
though didn't make it death screen yet
yeah I it can just reset is the thing it
probably you can just reset the
N uh when a player dies and then jeez so
the action space for spell selection
will be very
easy um the action space for targeting
is going to be pretty hard
though we're going to have to do some
stuff to get the action space for
targeting to
we also should probably just get like a
a general font that we use for puffer
because the default font is kind of
ridiculous I could just load that in as
a shared resource for
us I mean this is crazy good though
Nathan like this is going to
be um like a third hard complex Sim en
for training purposes
I got my two to finish right I got the m
and then the secret one to finish and
release um but yeah this is really good
I honestly didn't think that anybody
would like do something of this scope
for a while like this is
legit do you think I should put this on
the website yet would you like this on
the website yet or do you want to wait
until we do uh some of the RL stuff
contributors will start getting paid as
soon as there's
Revenue in the meantime this is open
source uh open source science
stuff I'm not like profiting off of
people's free work here believe
me and I've got a 10-year track record
of Open Source contributions to science
to back
that income will happen this is a very
new
guide are you meing like a build guide
for this RL environment or are you
looking for like how to like set up
puffer lib and
stuff I think I remember you off of DMS
earlier today if I am getting that
right um
yeah okay Nathan let me know if you want
this
uh Nathan let me know if you want this
on the web right now or if you want to
wait until uh there's more RL stuff I'm
happy to do either way um setup yeah so
easiest thing to get started with
puffer doc your friend
here if you want the docker version
there's a tank that set up up it's
assumes that you have an Nvidia GPU um
and if so it'll just work if not just
for
contributing you can just clone the repo
and check out the dev branch and then
pip install d e do and that should just
be all set up for you let me actually
comment the Coco thing real quick Nathan
cuz that's going to screw it up for
contributors on the dev
in now use it for something useful on
your
iPhone it's not be it's not B to
feel free to upload if it's quick
absolutely uh let me see what I'm going
to do with
that probably can just
well there's nothing to sell to
like the only people that there are to
sell this to are people who are
interested in doing RL in Industry the
pitch to those people is very simple RL
is very hard if you tried to do RL you
know that RL is very hard I'm an MIT PhD
who's been working in AI for over a
decade and RL for over seven years now
I've built a number of widely used open-
Source tools that make RL up to 100
times faster and much easier and you can
pay to have extended support around
those tools to make your work faster and
easier for
mean it's like pulling teeth cuz you're
peppering me with questions while I'm
trying to do stuff here and like this is
not this is not what the stream is for
right here let's put this on on the web
this will look
Nathan this solid
work oh jeez I'm going to have to
refactor the whole thing
though oh no it can go under the TCG the
snake
and I mean that's a solid project that's
like a really solid project I mean
that's something that would take me like
weeks as well that's like that's a very
solid contribution we're going to have
to do a lot of work to get the RL
working on this but that is
tactics you should be able to name it I
don't
if by consumer you mean customer we have
one we have a little landing page on
puffer doai and most of the most of the
actual like awareness about puffer comes
from my uh my
Twitter that's been incredibly effective
actually for getting uh word out there
and the growth has been
I mean it's been way more than anything
I expected at the very
least uh what happened
here
shot H we'll just
Photoshop me we just have like a basic
landing page for people
I mean
mostly mostly people want to uh you know
I set up meetings with
people I mean there's several sites like
there's puffer Dogg which has
environment demos there's puffer AI GI
habo which is our Dev site there's
puffer doai which is like the marketing
landing
page and we've got lots of
something happened
weird wasn't paying attention
oh I didn't mess up something weird that
just got
corrupted okay that was
weird whatever
look at
that look at
that now it doesn't uh load
apparently let's see why
right
H this doesn't load like a million
assets or anything right Nathan did you
like you didn't do like the pre-computed
path thing or something weird did
yet think I already have Flags in here
don't
isn't there like a Das s stack size or
something that I had to
upload I don't know what happened to
this
the
wow web dev is so brain
dead reducing stack size to like
insane no wonder uh none other stuff
works let me see if I can just real
quick what's
uh
here msdk flag to increase uh stack
online I don't know what it's doing that
it's lagging like this and then
not no errors no
warnings got to love webd
is my tactical oh uh I didn't check that
but it should be
fine did something hacky
there we'll see what you mean by
yeah this this doesn't work for
web this is why it's freezing the page
good thing that you uh you caught that
though it would have taken me a while to
figure that out to like realize to look
at your file I I would assume that you
just copi the
close you'll have to fix the keybind for
that
closed oh
jeez what's wrong with this thing
down cuz so here we
have like
one yeah okay so we'll have to fix that
there's no way to get out of spell
friend why the animations are so fast
it's literally going as fast as the
processor can
handle there you go isn't that
en still
no what do you mean still no
no it's not caching it's still
broken message file not
found uh is there what assets does this
thing need
Nathan oh I
know uh I think I
know no asset wait no
assets might not work with set Target
FPS
be there's a couple weird things that
you got to be careful about with uh with
web initialize
go there's a file not found thing which
is kind of
weird uh I don't know and it's not
telling
you have a map.
h that should be fine oh no wait that's
not fine wait is it I think map. H is
fine I
think it's included from the same
directory well I don't actually see the
file not found
here same as MOBA yeah
well I was asking cuz like the resources
direct removed right we have this
resources folder now where you can put
on o undefined
Behavior this is
that could be
bad hello
welcome okay this is this appears to be
stable locally now oh no it's
not what
happened
um hold on
this oh I hit QBE by mistake I've been
playing too much League of Legends which
is to say any League of
Legends all right what are the odds that
it works now I would say slim best
okay well that doesn't make sense it
should have been modified right
uh it's very weird that we don't have
any issues on this
um trying to think what else it would
be
huh works loow
found I don't know what the what was not
found but something was not found oh
that's bizarre now it works
randomly does it work without Dash
G hold
on I'd be very surprised if it doesn't
work maybe then it was actually cast
caching
well looks good
so once you figure out M scripton being
God
awful I mean this will be on the website
in just a couple
minutes it's at 5:29 I'm going to spend
a little bit of time on the rocket M
trying to figure some stuff out maybe
just making it look a little
better around six I'll um
I'll get up and head over to the gym but
then I will jump on uh I'll jump on the
Discord for anybody that wants to ask
stuff or like you know get onboarded or
whatnot here's your game live on puffer
Dogg playable
let's see if I were actually trying to
play this game what would I
do I'd
[Music]
probably do this and then I don't
actually know is this a retreat
Arrow oh no it's just a linear
okay so if I were actually trying to
play this game this is what I would
do but it's 2
a.m. that is how I would do
it I think that's the best first move I
don't
know all right uh I'll be right back uh
I'm going to use the restroom it's been
another half hour or so on Rocket EnV at
least clean up Graphics of it explo
explo yeah probably uh I'm going to
spend like another half hour on Rocket M
I'm probably just going to fix the
graphics up on it and we'll figure out
Dynamics tomorrow or
whatever and
um yeah and then I'll then I'll hop on
Discord after that I'll be right back
they'll give me a
day Friendly Fire is
enabled I really like this m though
Nathan I think this is going to be
really cool um you're probably going to
have to
code like some sort of basic scripted Ai
and then I'll have to work with you on
the action space a little bit for it um
you know like maybe you can add
something for like hostile NPCs you know
you can add some tofu or gobl or like
whatever like you know mobs um and then
what we can do is we can just reward it
for like inflicting damage or something
and I think we'll be able to get it to
learn
something just off of that but yeah this
is going to be a really cool M cuz it's
an M where like the actions space is
kind of tricky uh and there's a lot of
potential for interesting gameplay also
this just looks
sweet not selfplay at first we could do
selfplay
um we can do selfplay if you'd like
to it might be harder because you can't
the thing with selfplay is you can't
have like you don't have a metric
anymore that's just like run a is better
than run B without doing ELO and stuff
we can absolutely do like V5 PVP or you
know 8v8 PVP or whatever at some point I
think that it's going to be useful to
have like just some really dumb scripted
things like think about like the AI in
doofus right like tofu or goal or
something like that the AI is not that
complicated they mostly just run towards
you attack maybe they run away after
stuff like
that uh I don't think so bet because if
you use if you self buff then you can
get behind an obstacle and then they
can't hit you back with the strongest
H do you mind if I tweak a couple colors
Nathan if I do like the uh you know I
put like the Grid in like the dark can
and then like I convert these to be like
red and can instead of red and green and
stuff I figured I'd ask permission since
you put so much work into this this is
awesome all on the top of the dot h
perfect this is an awesome awesome m i
is it 2 am for you now or was it 2 am
before I I can mess with stuff now if
you want or we can set oh okay yeah no
then we're not do that now uh we can
I'll set aside a block of time though
I'm very happy to just like I can hang
out on Discord with you in or off stream
uh and we can just like go through and
figure some stuff out on this this is
like like really this is an awesome
contribution do I know your Twitter I
want to make sure I shout this
out when uh probably after I tweak a
couple graphics and at least get you a
better
follow
yeah this is awesome
work H you've got some good people
following you that's funny
sweet did you see the stuff on GPU drive
or were you working on
that I probably need to fix up the
puffer integration for Eugene by now
I've been too busy coding this and
working to beat Eugene to a th000
total oh yeah I saw this thing is this
one that you
made oh yeah you know this did you work
on this I don't
okay oh you worked on knockturn I see
okay
hey if you need bindings for uh this
stuff for puffer for your actual
research I can definitely make that
stuff
happen very cool
work oh okay
cool well hell I was addressing you like
you weren't a brand new to
RL you got already all sorts of cool
stuff that's a heck of a side project
getting that uh that M
done yeah but you only use the doctor
title when somebody's like being an
[ __ ] and insisting on you know being
referred to as like
it respected academics doctor and
they'll look at you weird and tell you
like dude I'm Joe or whatever
oh get but you're oh yeah Paris yeah of
course that makes sense cuz doofus
I'm not from Paris I just I found the
game on mini clip when I was like 10 and
got incredibly addicted to
it D what the heck was this box 2D
include
it's really funny too because like
literally the only games I've ever been
good at are
MMOs um I don't know I did all sorts of
crazy solo things in that and like I had
all sorts of crazy team stuff
the darn flags for
this l l box
duh how long are you up to I'm going to
start debugging my puffer issue soon uh
I'm going to just fix this for a bit and
then I'm probably going to stay I'm
going to stay say on voice in the
Discord but I'm going to go to the gym
most likely and then we'll see how much
energy I have after
that hold on so okay this is already
better just with the theming obviously
we now need to make this look like a
ship I actually really like like the
outline thing that I did earlier let me
see how to do that
today's been a crazy good day for puffer
good day to be a
puffer wait so you can't why is there no
rectangle
lines it also lets you do
annoying I mean I can just
like here I can just make one right
it's going to be two draw calls but I
can do
Pro kind of just want draw the lines of
this don't
you I guess as long as there's nothing
overlapping it's kind of okay
puffer issue is necessary to fix so that
we can start Pokemon really oh okay I
didn't realize that uh okay let me do
this real quick and I will I'll just
start on
that I thought this was like some random
thing that you were trying out cuz like
I didn't think that things had changed
with puffer from before right but I
guess they have somehow
he's setting up sweeps in Pro
oh
okay hold
on let me finish this thought and then I
guess I will do that
oh this has to go up because see it's a
little silly
I thought this was uh I thought the
error was something with resetting
M's okay there you go that's
like a fair bit cooler
looking we'll mess with this later
what's the thing with a puffer
let me
nice we got the uh the flags for the Mac
build very good
where is this getting
used yo B can you can you link me like
where this is getting
used like when is the m getting manually
reset like this
anyways I thought that they would be
getting recreated between sweeps I mean
between experiments on the same sweep
link me that I got one message to reply
to on X I think one more potential
wheat Branch yeah that guy I want to
know where it is that you're having to
do this resetting in the first
place
um is he still meming me all right
whatever maybe shouldn't have unmuted
him refactoring plus equl
light uh where's your branch of this
poke guess it's on the Discord hold
on this link thank
at okay so you're calling this twice you
have the the initial call at the start
which you want then what are you doing
with this
new oh because you're like making this
thing be your experiment
manager forcing a
reset so all M's
but I'm confused because that's not
actually a reset right that's like a a
simulator specific State set operation
isn't it like why do you have to call a
reset to do
this isn't it just like you send the
state and then in the environments the
individual environments are going to set
their state
I removed the async wrappers so then
what is this
doing or I'm trying to use SQ light as a
replacement but no you still have this Q
right this
thing look at the sqlite
wrapper well I see that you're getting
from the database you're getting State
stuff right but then
folder two ways of creating State
migrations but where does this get
called from doesn't this get this gets
called on
on the individual environment level
doesn't
it so this is called from the
subprocess so yeah then I don't
understand why you're trying to call
async reset you shouldn't have to call
the vectorized reset function you should
just be able to use this thing oh
because you made this a reset wrapper oh
um
o doesn't support put which it should
it's just like I didn't bother with that
feature because literally nobody used it
so it's like why am I going to maintain
this thing every time I screw with it if
nobody's using it
reset
jeez I'm trying to
think all right well I'll just go look
at code for
you uh this might end up having to
be h on the puffer
you're on 1 aren't you
okay let me see if I can just eyeball
it and figure out what's going on
here let me just eyeball see if I can
figure out what this is
ah
uh yo that guy um
do
send before you do
this yeah no it's just for now all you
have to do I think is you just call send
before
what was the other major one there was
one other
one n cuz the other the the double thing
is already resolved in
Dev
um let me look at your code real quick
you
wait am I reading this right have you
called send and then you call syn
call wait hold
on cuz if you call
send then it'll
step s equals
step what happens when you call send
is oh
wait receive pipe. receive
well this just 197 it's just going to be
it's just
looping because the
semor is greater than or equal to
main which means it's either in Mains or
infos
async
reset sends everything to
reset and then it calls send on the
pipes like
this the reset is zero
me actually should work as is um that
should work as is
I to write your Quick Test since this is
important
hold
on I got you
actually why does this not that should
be an error right there because it
doesn't receive
H cuz it's the mixing
apis yeah no that was
correct okay so we do receive send
receive send receive
send uh and then what do we do we
do like this and we see if it breaks
does not
[ __ ] what if I do like
num m is
30 or was it 20
40 num workers equals
2 batch size equal
20 let's see if this does
it it's probably a a race
40 M's two
workers maybe it's
this when you check for greater than
equal to
main I don't think it's the receive
pipe what I think is
happening
is hold
on so what I think is happening is
this here is setting it so you're
calling async reset and I think that
while you're calling async reset the
worker processes are still Computing
stuff and they're overriding this buffer
I think that's the most likely
thing because this doesn't
matter this shouldn't matter because
this is not doing a right operation this
is just reading so at worst this will
just make you sleep for an extra little
bit right I think that this is probably
the case but I can't reproduce
it I don't want to be the reason you put
a lock well it shouldn't
need it kind of will need to have a
thing on
that I can't put a lock there though is
the thing uh if you put a lock you kill
the entire perf of puffer
so you're going to have to just there's
going to have to just be like a clear
function or
something literally like the lock will
add 40 uh 40 micros seconds which is
more it's like twice the overhead of
this entire
thing so you like triple your
overhead am I doing something stupid
here why is this not why does this not
run why does my own API not
work num
workers bad
safe that's not a thing you can do
without a
receive we have to receive from
everything though
okay you can't do that
um you can't do that because in between
the check and its setting it can still
happen you're describing the exact use
case for a semaphor but the semaphor is
too
slow that's why we have an array called
sem
that's like not really a
semor why does this stupid thing not
work am I just being dumb like
have I've been coding for too long on my
own API or is the API
bad I think it is bad because they
should not be able to error like
that N
quars M's
workers and workers batch size back end
cereal I think I probably broke
something with the new
multiprocess I broke something here
oh wait did
I no I passed it here is native
it
01 the heck is happening here
seven viewers on
Twitch yeah Star Puffer for
sure more Dev daily and often cooler
stuff than this
debugging though this is this is
important unfortunately
gross why is it why do we get a zero in
here
I mean this is a separate problem
here I mean this is a separate problem problem though is the problem
I'm going to try this real quick if this
works I'm going to ship it if not I'm
going to give you what I think is
happening and then go to the gym because
I'm getting hungry here and I've been
working on this all
day um but I think I might have an idea
dude what the hell is wrong with this
pip
install
me dude it's like actually so hard to
stay ahead of what these P people
okay no I just improved it in 1.1 that's
one that's
fine okay so M send receive send
receive
async
yeah it's not getting
stuck um you see it's not
on that might be
it I think we got
it I think that's the Repro right there
right that's the race
it it's non- deterministic obviously
because it's a freaking race condition
you might actually get a rare 1 commit
right now it's not going to pip I'll
tell you
that but I will actually make it to 10
for
that wasn't that
bad little race
condition just a little race
condition what was the solution I was
looking away um you're not allowed to to
just continually receive until you clear
the buffer so I had to add a flush
method that just waits for all the
workers to be um to be
done should be compatible with
everything as
well manually call the flush yeah you'll
have to call the flush before you call
async reset but that's no big deal is it
I mean I can add it to Cal as well if
you just want to pass
stable there's no way to build it into
um oh I see what you mean uh
actually I might be able to do
that hold on I might be able to do that
for you I didn't think of it
yeah no it's fine I don't I don't care
about that
call
O suppos not oh cuz I don't have to call
flush anymore
I am hungry and still have two bench
weights before I can eat and I have
people to chat to with on the Discord so
I'm going to hopefully push you this and
then I'm going to go do
anything all right there's your PR I
mean there's your your fix that guy no
API changes whatsoever
um just built into V there you go
okay that is done um your fix is pushed
I am for folks watching here on YouTube
and twitch and X I suppose as well it's
been a pretty darn good day for this um
I am going to be on the Discord voice in
about 2 minutes if you want to chat if
you're interested in contributing if
you're interested in RL stuff uh yeah
I'll be around there pretty much the
only thing that you need in order to be
able to productively contribute to this
uh this type of work
is being able to write clean simple code
it's pretty much it yeah the M's a lot
of them are in C but it's really simple
C like first course uh undergrad system
programming C so yeah I will link
that
uffer also please St the repository I'll
be over there in the voice in general in
just a few minutes so don't be shy come
and say hi thanks all see you